I think individually we need to stop
relying on the government so I think one
of the things that is anybody that
pushed a lot of entitlements the last 60
years and got more Americans to be
relying on the government I think they
screwed America as well they got people
not to realize what their capabilities
capabilities are that's perfect but the
problem here for me
what I think immediately those are
long-term solutions for us to become
independent responsible not rely on a
government and take care of ourselves I
get it
but I also think this person we're
looking at to be able to get in there
and do the work is not going to be a
person that looks and walks and talks
the way you want that person well sure
but here's what I worry about too with
the 2024 election given how the other
elections have been what's going to stop
either side from being fraud right or
Russia get 2.0 or some other kind of
thing well the thing is our elections
the legitimate legitimacy of them is
already questioned by a massive portion
of the country after 2020. no but both
sides have been uh
flip it the other side it'll be the
other side again you know what I mean
something both of them do and we just
have to accept the fact that when people
you know NFL well they cheated that's
who won the soraki got it no problem
let's say Trump gets in the National
Security State and all these other
institutions hate him right and and they
all put their weight behind the fraud
claim what happens then to say well they
cheated to do oh oh yeah that there was
cheating that there was whatever foreign
but my concern is I think we are we have
already really started to move away from
democracy that we are currently living
in illusion of democracy let's go back
to Republic where the individual is
protected because right now the
individual is not but think about the
DNC even in the primaries with Bernie
Sanders yeah they're cheating them I
mean they they screwed him totally yeah
right he was he was the guy and now
they're saying they won't even have a
debate debate in the Democratic primary
because the RFK Junior against Biden so
what's your solution though what's your
solution so so for example you're saying
what if we get this person Trump wins
and the santis wins okay what if we get
RFK then once what if we get you know
Biden demos we know what's going to
happen at Biden that's right we know
what's good yeah but if Trump wins and
he goes in or DeSantis when he goes in
there's a difference between those two
winning if Trump wins and he goes in
they're gonna try to do everything they
can and everything's been false Durham
report you know the recent thing
Clinton's involvement Obama's
involvement there's so many things that
have been proven that were fake The
credibility but what's been done
what's where's the accountability from
who's in his end from anyone's end all
these people I mean the the stuff that
has been these people people have gotten
away with in an actual election
interference kidding me like you know
who you know who was enemy to state
number one when Trump was president
no I'm not talking I'm talking about
like the russiagate stuff oh yeah and I
don't think I don't think I think and
honestly those guys are morons if they
keep doing that because that business
model is not working for them they keep
losing money when they do the MSNBC I'm
not creative either I mean but the point
is let them do that they have they have
no moral Authority Democrats this guy
was a guy that believed in the Russia
stuff first time him and I spoke when I
was going to bring him here to be with
us on the team I didn't know if I was
ready for a guy like this I question I'm
like what do you think about this can
you reason are you able to do this well
I think I said what do you think about
the Russia deal eventually he came in
and now he reads it he says I can't
believe they did this so and he's a guy
that is a worker he's independent he
doesn't rely on the government he takes
care of himself he's done very well for
himself and now he's sitting there
saying yeah I don't know if I like I'm
not a trump guy but I don't know what
they're doing here there is more people
in his Camp sure and then can I just
submit one thing we talked about this
list of Institutions that have basically
harmed America the number one item on
this list that we left out is the media
and mainstream media and the lies the
narratives if they told the American
public and I'm the I'm a type of person
that Prides myself on digesting a whole
appetite of media especially now but
there's a there's a wide swath of
Americans that are just basically just
peripherally reading the news yeah I
guess it's russiagate thing yep I guess
they uh yeah the January 6th thing I
guess the Dominion thing there's it's
like we don't have time to basically
pick apart each of these stories like
we're all not Whitney Webb we can
diagnose all these wild different
stories and just accumulate them and
diagnose them most people are like yeah
I guess there's a Russian thing going on
Boom here's what concerns me though so
based on what you guys have been saying
and it's very true collapse in
mainstream media is collapsing and we're
in a very different position now than
2016 or really any other time as far as
that metric is concerned but what
concerns me is that okay so with covet
you had this huge push to turn
everything move everything to the
digital sphere right and at the same
time you're trying to move everyone
everything all stuff online but you're
also making this big push to control
what's online yeah and so you're having
this push uh to censor you know I get
Twitter files touched on that obviously
and there's this this talk from like
Matt taibi and others about the
censorship industrial complex that is a
very real thing and you know for someone
like me the threat of censorship is very
real you know I did Real uh factual
reporting on stuff going on with
covid-19 and I lost my patreon they
admitted that there was nothing untrue
in the report they censored me for but
they thought it might affect vaccine
uptake and so they took away all my
money money well Woody doesn't it just
all come down to one word which is
control it doesn't want to control what
you say they want to control you spend
your money they were going to show you
social credit scores this is why I
mentioned there's this push into these
digital systems everything's going to be
online or on the cloud or whatever and
at the same time they're controlling
they're making an unprecedented push for
control over that digital sphere so
we're being herded to a place and
they're creating all of these all of
this infrastructure to control what we
can see in here once we're all stuck
there essentially so you have collapse
and Trust of mainstream media the goal
it seems like is to take out everyone
that won't say what mainstream media
says and at the same time you're having
mainstream media creepingly being
replaced by a chat GPT and things like
that they're saying that by 2025 90 of
all the content media content online is
going to be chat GPT generated right so
you don't have regular people telling
you what to say how are people going to
know what's real and what's not at that
point and now there's all this talk of
deep fakes AI art has gone into this new
era you can make anyone with air be in a
picture with Jeffrey Epstein you know
what I mean so you know this is a really
unprecedented situation and to think
that these institutions we've been
listing off those actors wouldn't it go
you know throw the kitchen sink at us uh
to get what they want you know I think
that might be kind of naive to think
that because you know this is they're
making a total push for control
and they're going to put out all the
stops because if they don't get it they
lose right and stuff will start to come
out they don't want that to happen you
know so this is they're giving it their
all and I don't think they're going to
win at the end of the day but how much
damage do they cause they've only been a
plenty of plenty of damage well and I
was going to say uh because Pat I think
it was the podcast with Giuliani in them
where we were talking about the hope and
having hope and having faith not losing
all that hope but because just from
everything that we talked about winning
from Epstein to these guys it's like are
we wasting our time I I 100 appreciate
getting it out there getting the word
out there but are we wasting our time in
the sense that these people have set up
the pieces of the game where no matter
what we could literally just like the
whole the Durham report came out FBI
Department of Justice Obama
administration Hillary they all pedaled
this line the whole brush along it was
all Bs they framed Michael Flynn
three-star General it just came out the
reports in your face nobody's gonna go
to jail Hillary's gonna walk free
nothing happens so are we just wasting
our time with all the these all these
just evil players because not at the end
of the day what what really happens to
them yeah so the the lack of
accountability thing is a major problem
and again I think the main issue we need
to be looking here is public trust right
there's no public trust in the media
there's the public trusted institutions
is dwindling but what do those
institutions do when they realize no one
trusts them anymore
they're not going to give up control
easily you know what I mean so what are
they planning to do
and this is why I always go back to this
stuff that's been set up by the bite
Administration but it's antecedents go
before Biden this war on domestic Terror
infrastructure all of the people that
were counter-terror experts and
developing AI to hunt insurgents in Iraq
are now developing Ai and policies to go
after regular Americans that are accused
of domestic Terror and if you read the
policy papers from the bite
Administration their definition of what
is a domestic terrorist is extremely
broad it's extremely broad it includes
people who don't like uh even on the
left uh the advance of like multi-north
National corporations and like global
capitalism and stuff are people who are
perceived as being too anti-authority
and too anti-government or parents
speaking up at school board meetings
saying they don't want their kids uh
learning about sex and they're yelling
at those things they're like domestic
terrorists so the problem is you know
how are they how are they trying to do
this it's with AI it's with what it's
data mining off of social media I would
say if people really want to show shut
down this machine get off of Legacy
social media okay yeah but again like
you know I know that's hard for people
because people are so into it and like
me as a journalist a lot of people don't
read my stuff if I don't use it and blah
blah blah but you have to look at what
they're setting up and they wouldn't be
setting up this war on domestic Terror
infrastructure where it could be you
unless they were planning to use it at
some point and all they need Bill Barr
said it uh a few years ago when he was
attorney general uh he was talking about
getting a back door in encryption
eliminating essentially any sort of
privacy enhancing technology for the
public he was saying at some point
there's going to be a a big event that
will Galvanize public opinion around
these issues sort of reminds me about
the peanut new Pearl Harbor stuff before
9 11 you know
um but it's true you have this one
crisis that comes and there's all this
fear this is the Boogeyman this is what
we have to do to stop it because if you
think like I mentioned earlier we're
being herded into this Corral of you
know the digital control grid I guess
and they're trying you know and
historically what I think it's the
carrot in the stick you know what I mean
yeah I'll totally get that and it
explained very clearly
but you know
um
you know the whole thing when some
people say well you know what if you
only had one hour to live what would you
do
look dude if I had one hour to live I
wouldn't be here right now I'd stay home
do that
so let me get this straight for the rest
of the year you want me to treat
my life as if I only have one hour to
live yeah I'd be home for the entire
year
so is that what you want me to do well
no still be effective but what if you
had one hour to live dude I get that and
I've said this myself it's an element of
this is why I think I'm working too hard
this is why I'm doing this gocha so
there's so many arguments with
contradictions that we all give our
parents told us we tell our kids we tell
our audience you know the media tells us
leaders tells us books tells the world
is filled with a lot of contradictions
and somehow some way we have to find
some level of reasonable decision for us
to make that comes with contradictions
for example
you know to solve things like well why
we you know one person is not going to
save this and it's not it's not it's got
to be us
okay I think that's partially true
long term it's got to be us yeah but it
was one person that was able to have the
courage to go against Hitler
and it wasn't Chamberlain
was another guy named Churchill and if
there is no Churchill
with the fearlessness that he had no
matter how much you talk about his
past how he was who you know husband you
know if there's no Churchill you and I
are probably speaking German right now
or the world will be a different world
today okay every once in a while during
times like this you still have to have
somebody speak on your behalf I'm not
sure a lot of people like follow your
content they feel like you're speaking
for them so why why do you do so well
because there's millions of people
around the world that are saying dude
she's speaking she's she's me I feel
like she's talking on my behalf great I
think we need somebody that's going to
get up there and piss a lot of people
off when I see candidates that are
already broker and deals with everybody
pre-election I already know that
person's not going to do what American
needs to do today I already know that
person going to get into the White House
and they're going to do what hey I'm
into the White House on this
you know the person to do that I still
do believe because the the angle of just
thinking it's us that that gets us from
not trusting in the voting system
and even if you show up to vote here's
what I mean when I say you know the one
guy thing one guy can't save it because
what happens is a lot of people feel
like oh as long as I vote for that one
guy and he gets in and I don't have to
do anything I don't agree with more yeah
but that's how a lot of people react
okay so I'm not saying we shouldn't you
know they're no good you're not hitting
a good guy or a better guy in the White
House you don't I don't no but there are
people that do that and so that's why I
try and stress in my work especially in
today's climate I mean there's this
crazy banking crisis going on and it's
not going to get better before it gets
worse sure right so what do you do
tomorrow if you wake up and uh your
money's gone right what are you gonna do
are you going to feed your family what
if the internet's shut down you know all
this I mean I encourage people to think
about that type of building that type of
resilience in their lives because the
the less dependent you are in the system
the less the harder it is for you to be
enslaved by that system 100 you know so
that's what I'm trying to say about you
know personal responsibility and stop
Outsourcing your needs to the these
people in this system right would it be
better to get someone who who speaks
truth to power into the White House I'm
not saying it's that would be bad at all
what I'm saying is a lot of people tend
to go back you know to sort of armchair
activism or you know political season's
over I'm not going to fight for my
rights anymore because now I've got the
guy up there I do I do think and that's
a problem with somebody to speak on your
behalf yes sir but the problem is a lot
of people like to not do anything you
know what I mean the reality is the
predo theory has been around for a while
the 80 20 ruled 80 is not going to do
anything anyway so we're not relying on
the 80 to do something I've been part of
the 80 when I was trying to get
everybody else to save my life and I'm
like this doesn't work I want to be
part of the community that can stand up
and be responsible for themselves and I
shifted that's I had a 1.8 GP in high
school trust me there's no one in high
school that's going to say Patrick but
David was going to do something big with
his life finally I'm like get off your
ass and go do something I joined the
army at 18 life change so I'm I'm with
you there but I also do believe the this
notion like you know how single men and
women who wait until they get married
what's the problem the older you get
what is the problem are you married I
don't know if you're married or not
married with kids okay so
okay so so the whole concept with
marriage right the whole concept with
marriage
um you wait to get married okay wait
till uh 35.
what's your 40.
with your 45 way 250 what's the problem
the longer we wait until we get married
what are we really saying to the world
what we're really saying to the world is
what I'm gonna wait until I find what
the perfect person guess what good luck
the older you get the harder it's going
to be to find that perfect person right
so there is part of that argument that
also has a leak in it there is risk in
marriage right there is risk in having
kids there's risk in saying I think this
guy could be the right guy but it's even
riskier to say no no no no no I'm not no
no no no no I'm not going to do this
there's risk you know there's risk
relationships don't work you know kids
don't there's there's pain in that it's
tough so I think for us the one part I
absolutely agree with that we got to
take full responsibility I think the
other part is as well hey who do you
think that is the least corrupt person
that is not loved by the corrupt
institutions that you think could go and
fight these corruption that has the
highest likelihood try to support that
person if you think it's a RFK go for it
if you think it's tulsing but if you
think it's a even a Libertarian girl we
had a guy named Dave Smithy I actually
like this guy I hope he does something
if it's a Dave Smith go for it if you
think it's a trump go for it if you
think it's Lord but find someone that
you think could fight that corruption
what I like about vivec is he's ran a
company that's worth a couple billion
dollars and he's calling out all the
he's calling out all these weird
institutions support a guy like that so
do be independent but also do sell and
support the guys that you think have the
highest likelihood of fighting the
things that you also want someone to
fight for I think both are necessary so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]